we began thinking about story we began
thinking about songs we began to think
about the environments it was of course
it was going to take place in our world
we knew that but somehow we also
had to bring something new to it we like
to think of it as turning the world you
already know inside out and revealing
more that was already there not going
outside the edges of the town but
almost almost unfolding the town like
one of these toys you know you had when
you were a kid where you could open the
house and and see inside i like that
x-ray vision into some of these places
that you've already seen on the series
but
we had a very specific problem from the
beginning which is how do you tell a
story that doesn't break the show a
movie is an exciting event in which
characters are transformed their lives
are forever changed i mean that's that's
you know the best kind of storytelling
in uh in a feature film but we can't
change our character's lives so
significantly that you can't go back and
watch the television show it has to
somehow
exist within the world of the tv show
and so we
cook that story for a long time we baked
it and took it out and stuck a fork in
it to see if the middle was soft and
then we baked it some more it was a very
long process breaking that story and
writing that script partly because
we couldn't settle for anything less
than the movie that advanced
some aspect of the characters lives and
changed some deep part of them but left
you back at the beginning able to pick
up the next day go back to work and be
this little struggling restaurant
you